foreign
together you should try giving up
is tight
[Music]
Julio still living with your mom nah I
moved out damn y'all living in the
garage is sad I got a garage you
know who live up in there a car not two
Mexicans
I got all this energy and I don't know
what to do with it hey my man did you
just go around being all rude and
is that a cufflink in the bucket you
want to come in here and steal for me
now hey
[Music]
I found my place out here in the desert
there's a tranquil energy there's
actually a frequency that I've tuned
into if you listen you can hear it
what's going on
hugs not thugs was a non-profit to help
ex-gang members but it's shelled I've
moved on and you should too damn
Minister Payne hasn't
[Music]
it
we're opening up a cafe it's gonna be
just like Hog's not bugs but we need you
what's the plan it's gonna be like
Starbucks but better we're not gonna
have no bathroom code we gotta have
bathroom clothes human beings are
animals
[Music]
got a new philosophy to chaos we're
gonna have a legacy my kids could work
here yeah but they'd have to be
ex-felons
[Music]
everything happens for a reason
especially in this city we're gonna call
it mugs not bugs man that's a clean ass
here uh for the record I don't think
that this the best slogan for this part
of ballet
[Music]
chick you're dating as a kid yeah that
kid's gonna be crying to some shrink
because their mom dated a loser who
lived in a garage and stunk up the
bathroom I don't think of the bathroom
you're rotting from the inside
[Music]